this man's podcast highly popular
podcast green light with chris long
uh is uh available for download where
all podcasts
are acquired chris long back here on the
rich eisen show how are you sir
dude great plug i would say moderately
successful podcast that's what we say
no why would you why would you downgrade
yourself well it's always
it's always good to under promise over
deliver rich okay
uh i appreciate that uh what do we make
of pro days
should we make anything of these pro
days that we're seeing right now jamar
chase running uh
sub 4-4 chester pitts tight end four
four four
do we what what should we make of these
proteins i mean they matter
um we're let's let's face it we're
flooding these pro days because we have
nothing else to do right mostly right
you know well you it is i guess also uh
content of interest we hope
yeah it's conte i can't pretend that i i
wake up every morning and think about
the nfl first
you know like there's march madness and
they're talking about pro days and how
fast guys are running
yeah it's great i mean like i watched
kyle pitts run that 40.
he stacked an imaginary linebacker in a
4-4-5
and like he didn't even run a straight
line like i don't care about his time as
much i care about how it looked it
looked amazing
so what was your pro day like chris
man listen my pro day i refused to do
all the like all the time drills i just
did drills with my head coach al grow
because i knew i was going to the
combine anyways
you know it's like um and
each kid's got a decision to make with
that obviously this year is a little bit
different but
you know i think more than anything if
you just show up uh good talent
evaluators can tell who's athletic
and who's football you know um whose
skill sets going to translate onto the
field so the times are great they're
flashy
but half of them i joked last year like
i just ran a 4-4 at my pro day
i tweeted it so it must be true like
you know i've heard of teams shortening
their 40 you know
their length of 40 by a couple feet come
on on their feet you like come on like
these teams is in their best interest
that these players go high right
so i you know i take everything with a
grain of salt and as somebody who rushed
the passer as expertly as you did and
was drafted as high as you were
chris long the concept of football on a
stick
using the football on a stick to
simulate a snap for a pro day or a
combine drill
it is indispensable correct the football
is sick football on a stick is
indispensable i started a football on a
stick
for a combined one year my life in
d-line indy
drills so right that's how it's going to
be man get used to the football and
stick thank you very much chris long i
knew i had you on for a reason here on
the rich eisen show
what do you make of a 17-game schedule
alvin camaro
tweeted out his disgust at the subject
what do you think and what are you
hearing amongst your
colleagues in the nfl who actually have
to suit up for 17 games what they think
of it
well they seem pretty unhappy and i
don't blame them because they gave up
you know a lot um that one game's big
right you know you get like a little bit
more of the revenue
but without a second buy it's gonna be
you know it's gonna be tough and i think
a lot of it's gonna fall back on coaches
the
me the consumer the quasi media member
whatever like
my biggest thing is how the hell do we
talk about records you know people are
talking about this like
i'm not doing i heard you talking about
this like best 17 game stretches and
comparing them like
listen we've been talking about thousand
yard receivers you gotta have a thousand
sixty two yard season now
i'm talking about 2000 yard rushers 2124
yards
that's that's where i'm going with it i
i refuse to
like double digits used to be a big deal
if you got double digits and sacks
how many guys are gonna get double
digits now every year you know it's just
like it's a weird thing
it's gonna be even harder to compare
eras and i hate that because we're so
bad at it now
but for players yeah it kind of sucks um
but a lot of it's gonna be who's your
coach does the coach get it
um because if a coach gets it i would
play 17 games for a coach that that gets
it over 16 for a coach that doesn't get
it how do you re
define gets it then chris what knows how
to take care of players you know what i
mean like knows when to take the foot
off the gas pedal
the new cba handcuffs these coaches a
little bit you know
um and that's a good thing because left
of their own devices we'd be doing
oklahoma drills in
december and that just doesn't jive with
performance i can remember
ironically the most fresh i ever felt in
my tenure in philly was
when we got ready for a playoff game
17th game of the season and that was
because we started walking through
you know we started doing some of those
things including the super bowl run so
you know like coaches are going to have
to
really dig deep and find some empathy
so using your phrases you're going to be
tired so using your
your phrase chris long of gets it which
coach of yours that you had in the pros
got it the best
jeff fisher got it the best okay
why you know um jeff fisher was like
we did a lot of things wrong in st louis
but we played fast and we played
physical you know what i mean and so
from a player
from a player um looking out for the
players bodies
sleep rest like all that stuff matters i
know the coaches sleep three hours a
night
but that's their choice we didn't ask
them to look at the same cut ups over
and over again like
players we actually have to recover
physically so from everything down to
like when do you get guys in the
building for treatment in the morning
you know if it's if it's january and
you're getting ready for week 17 and i
have a i rolled my ankle
i don't tell the trainers i gotta be in
there five in the morning i'm tired
you know so like all that stuff adds up
like top to bottom
how do you focus a little bit more on
helping your players recover and that's
the coaches who are gonna have to do
this so then is it
unfair or patently unfair that when the
17th game got announced jeff fisher
trended on twitter because he can't go
seven and nine anymore chris
well i thought you'd bring that up and
say that's funny but like you know and
and the thing about fish is and i always
take this opportunity to say that he's
one of my favorite coaches i've ever had
and and one of the best coaches i had in
a lot of ways you know like
um we just couldn't get over the hump
offensively but you talk about guys
being the super bowl
he's pretty damn good about taking those
jokes on the chin he actually has a
twitter account which is
just very brave and i
i i bring it up also saying i guess it
is unfair
uh to say that because the guy did go to
the super bowl he coached many of the
terrific tennessee titans teams
wound up one she one yard shy against
ironically enough the rams franchise
that uh that you uh played for uh
as a player for him who made that tackle
rich uh
that would be you know machine matchup
jones match
that's the reason i know and i met mike
jones the the the other mike jones the
guy who made the tackle he's super cool
no i know that
and jeff was phenomenal in the in the uh
as
you know talking in the media to about
uh the competition committee he was on
that for for many many years
yeah he's a good caring guy man like he
cares about his players so i mean i
think you know anybody could take a page
from a coach like that
you know like when it's time to work
it's time to work but knowing what
you've got ahead of you now like
that extra game is a big deal and we
don't know how much of a big deal it is
because
after a year or two we're gonna have
studies on injury rates and that sort of
thing and
um shoot you see some of these contracts
you want you pay me five seven million
dollars i'll
i'll play 17 with a smile on my face
what the hell
but i also get it we didn't give up we
didn't get a lot in return here
well i mean there there is the matter of
chris long here on the rich eyes show
what do you say to the fact that
the the pot that the nfl just acquired
from all of these
uh media companies deep into you know or
or
into the next decade that equals a
hundred billion dollars that the cap
should go up i mean that should put more
money
right that's but that's it should put
more money in the pockets of players
that 17th game it absolutely should
um and man if
i thought go won't go broke was the
saying i thought that like
i thought we weren't going to make any
more money as a league uh because
players were speaking out
on issues they cared about but uh those
maybe those numbers aren't real i think
that eventually players
do see like that kind of baseball money
but it's gonna be interesting like
you know because not everybody's gonna
get that baseball money and like uh
i feel like it's been a weird offseason
i think it's been about the haves and
the have-nots and the caps down
so there's a lot to consider chris long
here on the rich eisen show
what happened in philadelphia that
you're uh um
um up for sharing chris
cause you want to talk about weird um my
gosh uh
doug peterson three years after a super
bowl
um you know is bounced a new coach comes
in
and his first press conference in
philadelphia certainly does not
give credence to the sense that you have
to have a certain media savvy to be a
coach
in philadelphia um and then there's a
trading down of a draft choice that
man did they earn by sitting jalen hurst
in game 256 that got the whole country
up in arms uh yeah you know what i mean
so
so what in the world ha what can you
what can you share with me
on this man i you know in general at
this point i'd rather chew glass
and talk about the eagles off season
because it's just been so repetitive and
like everything i say gets
shared like i basically grabbed a
megaphone on broad street was like hey
you guys should care what i think
for the record i'm on the rich eyes and
show and rich asked me about it did
ask you i flat out and asked you chris
i am soliciting your response this is
not any sort of
important intel on the eagles i don't
listen man like
i've said it before um
i it's been confusing at times like
what's going on there
uh but that's okay i i don't think we
always need to know what the hell is
going on as long as you hit on these
picks
you know the end result of all the
carson stuff
all the jalen hurt stuff that week 17
thing
um you know is you're sitting here with
11 picks
you've traded back um there's a
possibility you have three first round
picks next year which are predicated on
the performance of two other franchises
and a player who you have good reason to
like in a classy way if you're howie
roseman you're probably rooting against
carson's success
because 75 snaps making the playoffs all
those things
you know um all those things factor into
does philly get that draft pick
um best case scenario for philly if i
remember correctly would be
carson plays seventy five percent of the
snaps and plays them into a top ten pick
yes i think is unlikely right i think
he's going to play well
i think they're going to at least have a
bottom 10 pick from indy i think they
probably have a bottom 10 pick from
miami
um so the scary thing from them is
if they play their way into the middle
of the first round yes they have a bunch
of position players that they could take
a stab
at but by making the decision
that jalen's your guy and i really like
jalen hurts
i wish he was in a better situation
because it's chaos right now
um it's not going to be easy to get the
best out of a young player
but you know good luck i think i i think
he's got the mental fortitude
if he plays you into the middle of the
first round
in 2022 what year is it
um if he plays in the middle first round
who who the quarterbacks in that draft
class
well we don't know and a lot of people
die after a year then what do you do
i think that's the scary confusing part
and philly fans are like obsessed with
kyle pitts i don't know if you read the
internet
you can't draft kyle pitts anymore so
like you could be sitting here in a year
um and you could have a lot of people
pretty unhappy with your intentions are
pretty high in philly so it's just a
huge year for howie
huge year for for that entire
organization and
how he's done some good things before 11
picks you know and support jalen
here's another thing rappaport said it
they tried to move up to two
like i don't know like if you don't
believe ian or not but like that makes
sense that they would try to move up to
two zach wilson if you think he's that
good
you know um you take a stab at them for
the men the reasons i mentioned so
um i think they know that your jets are
gonna take zach wilson and i think
that's why they moved back
right and and and they moved back
because you know if you're not gonna get
the quarterback that you want and you
feel that you could get the same value
at 12 or similar at six
uh i i i do read the internet i had in
the sec and when i was talking the first
hour of the show about the pro days
saying it's a bad pro day for
philadelphia
because both jamar chase and kyle pitch
are showing out and i think
eagles fans thought they had a shot at
either one of those two maybe
uh even a choice heaven forbid for them
at six and now there's no shot
on this philly green earth man the
eagles the eagles fans are gonna hate
like lsu wide receivers would just
trigger
justin jeffrey you went to jalen rieger
for me right there
and chris long i know you're savvy
enough to understand the way i'm trying
to take another uh
crack at this subject matter uh with
this question so i
even front load it in that regard no
problem are you pro
no uh uh what sort of quarterback are
colts fans gonna get in carson wentz
i think you know what i really think
people are gonna be surprised i do
um but it's just become such a
polarizing conversation
you know like you either gotta love
carson or hate him like and that's
he's just become the morning tv topic he
was there for like a solid three four
months i saw people
with veins bulging in their necks that i
just didn't even know were there like
they were so upset about the carson
thing i was like
of all the topics this guy must did he
like kick a puppy
in front of you or something like the
guy was in a terrible situation
and they picked jalen and that's fine
that's the business
and you know he wanted out so i think
he's going to be in a market
that better suits him from like a
microscope
um you know standpoint like it's the
market's just a little bit different
he's
he's not like maybe a guy who naturally
would love like a big big city with all
that media scrutiny
um and he's also going to be on a team
where although they do actually have to
shore up their offensive line more than
you think
he's just going to be in a more a more
cohesive situation
and frank reich who he's had um
obviously a
you know a well-covered history with is
going to help a lot so
i think you're going to get a a middle
of the road quarterback which is very
good in the nfl at worst
i think that if you if you get anywhere
near your 2017 he's going to be in the
top ten
and that's probably an upgrade even
though philip played really well
if he's a top 10 quarterback well he and
and and just to
finish up the subject matter the thing i
just don't understand is and
the things i hear all the time from
michael irvin on my set and when sapp
was on the set and falk was on the set
for nfl network is that
quarterbacks you know when they get the
competition they they don't like it
and they they act in a way that
not a single other person on a field
defensive player
other offensive player is allowed to act
when somebody else is drafted to give
them competition or back them
up and so i don't understand why the
drafting of hertz would send them in
such a
thing that's really i also think that's
really easy for hall of famers to say
okay so they're so secure in who they
are like
dudes in every locker room watch the
draft and dudes are sour when you draft
somebody at a position where you're
going to share
time with them i've been pissed off that
they drafted somebody
you know i got my position and i had and
i was in the franchise court the thing
about quarterback is
if you're out you're out like they don't
rotate you so like
you know it's funny i just feel like a
lot of times it's like
do we like the guy personally no i give
him latitude i'm not talking about you
rich i'm talking about like
just anybody breaking down a player well
we like player mobility we we want
players to be on the move and
express their displeasure but if it's a
guy we don't think has a case
then just shut up and and that and and
that sort of thing like
me with carson is listen has carson
perfect there
no you know i've said this before like
nick foles is a rare leader carson could
learn something from him about that but
that's not to say he's not a good leader
you know um but everything's been a or b
it's been carson or nick
carson or jalen and you can't have a b
conversations then
not expect the quarterback to say well
if this is an a b
conversation i don't want to do the joke
but i'm out of here no i i hear you it's
just
it it doug peterson at times was
sticking with a
way longer than what i thought you know
any other coach would he even said one
ballot
you know i i he came we went to the
microphones at one point if i go to jail
and hurts i'm telling the
the team the season's over and jalen
when he finally turned him damn near
saved it
yeah well jalen breathed in new life but
you also don't know if
he went to jail in mid-season you know
because the production tailed off a
little bit you just don't know how eight
games that would would have been and so
i think if if for anything they should
have done it earlier
so that they had a bigger picture into
what they have this year
you know and i think and as much i
support carson i've said this a million
times before
that benching was warranted i mean he
played himself into that
but they also assisted him
into playing like that a little bit as
well i mean that was just
it had been a rough couple years stretch
there and um
you know fresh start for him um i'm sure
fans are not as and i don't blame them
because they buy tickets and that sort
of thing and they want performance
i'm sure fans are not as patient as a
player that's played with you know guys
but
i just you know i'm rooting for him so
you know i think he's a good dude
i think it just became such a character
assassination conversation
and anytime somebody asked me about it
i'll just repeat the same thing i
you know he's not a bad guy he could
work on some things leadership and
locker room wise reaching out to every
corner of the locker room
you know i had malcolm jenkins on my pot
he said the same thing great guy
could be more social he'll work on those
things in in indy he's got to work on
the football though that's the thing
rich
if he's doing what he did in 2017 how
much did you hear about his leadership
so i just want to let everyone
understand um
i invited chris long on the on the show
um
i solicited his thoughts on the
philadelphia eagles on the show i want
everyone to understand
how this all just went clickbait man i
really don't care
by the way we don't now hold on a second
are you saying i'm i'm i invited you on
for clickbait or i'm not
just no not you but i'm not gonna be
turned into clickbait
well you wanted to talk about the niners
too sure you got a sec
if you got a second chris if you gotta
say you know
kyle kyle going to the chiefs you want
to hit me on that one
we could do that i'm pretty excited
about that i'm pretty excited about that
that seems like uh
you know watching him play on sundays in
chicago it could be tough
it's going to be a lot easier on the
eyes uh in kansas city and that's not
that it's just like it's tough i've been
on teams that were struggling or 500 or
below he's not going to have that
problem anymore all right chris long
uh i appreciate you being on this show
everybody check out greenlight with
chris
long uh where all podcasts can be
acquired and gotten it is not
moderately good it is a very good it's
an excellent pod hold on it's one of the
best podcasts out there
keep going guys you just want to keep on
heat yeah do you want to talk about the
niners
i mean sure what do you think's going on
in that locker room as they're about to
draft the third overall pick rookie
quarterback and they went to the super
bowl with jimmy g two years ago what do
you think is going on there chris
well i think it just teaches us not to
listen to gm's and coaches in like
february or whenever we were like oh
jimmy's used their guy you know like and
everybody was like oh they said it i'd
if i hear another person
on yeah i don't hear it if you read the
internet and you see another person
talking about like well this coach or
this gm said that like jams and coaches
don't tell you the public anything dude
so like so i really i really think maybe
we should just wait until they tr
it's like when jeffrey lurie said you
know jalen hurts our guy
and then you read that they're moving up
or trying to move up yeah you know um
and that's the thing about the nfl which
is tough business and it sucks for jimmy
because the timing is going to be
probably
they they get the guy they want they
they live happily ever after
jimmy's got a no trade clause right so
it could be
probably like denver new england denver
i don't think he's enough to get denver
over the hump in that division i mean
that respectfully
to denver and to jimmy but i think new
england's the chalky answer and i think
that's what ends up happening
and i would i would venture to guess
like everybody's okay with that because
you're gonna have a young exciting
prospect and you know what your ceiling
is with jimmy you like jimmy
but you know what the ceiling is so what
happens with cam if jimmy goes to new
england and you say the chalk happens
you well you you [ __ ] cam at such a i
mean like it was funny the first day was
like oh
15 million for the year he had last year
like look at the contract it's like five
or six million for the most part
um it's it's heavily incentive laden
and you look at you know
jimmy who's got a an issue with
durability and cam
i don't blame him he's played like a
linebacker for 11 years who also plays
quarterback
you just don't know so you got two guys
with durability issues you could
probably have them at
a lower price and cam at worst is a
great guy you can throw into packages
like cam i would rather play taysom hill
than
then i sent cam newton in a package like
that i hear you
i hear you and you know what i'm saying
so i think they'd have good options
there
okay by the way as we say goodbye to
chris long uh the reason why he brings
up they want to talk about the niners
because i texted him yesterday things i
want to talk to him about it's this very
subject so i appreciate you circling
back and bringing that up
the last one too the last one too is how
you know the bucks bringing back all of
their players from the super bowl all 22
starters
and how brady probably you know uh went
ahead and recruited a lot of them to
come back just like
i'm sure he did for chris long and what
was your response what was your response
to that
the funniest thing is you you're trying
to you're trying to make it like
personal to me you're like oh that's the
thing i could talk about you were like
uh you know like the bucks brought back
all their players did you see the news
like probably a lot like brady recruited
you
uh when you left new england yeah i said
actually you're not gonna believe this
but i
i decided to leave like right after the
super bowl
and so he just knew he wasn't getting me
back that's why he didn't recruit me
but it's funny that bruce arians came
out and said the camp is going to be
like the hardest in the history of
training camps after he got everybody
signed back
[Laughter]
slick you're the man chris thanks for
the time i love
our chats best your whole family please
send my best everybody
right back at you that is chris long oh
my gosh
every word when we chat with him i love
talking to him
so smart so funny gosh
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here